[Music]
what's up Wolfgang this morning on Good
Morning America they showed us a new 27
second clip of Avengers infinity war
we'll show you the scene and then I'll
dissect it after but don't forget to hit
that subscribe button to stay up to date
on Avengers infinity war
[Music]
[Music]
the structure has polymorphic right we
had to attach each neuron non non
sequential why didn't you just reprogram
the synapses to work collectively
because we didn't think of it I'm sure
you did your best so in a video I did
not too long ago I talked about how I
think Cherie is going to save vision and
that's exactly what I think is going on
in this clip they're obviously trying to
figure out a way to get the soul stone
out of vision sherry scans them and then
her technology shows her how the soul
stone is connected to vision as she
scans him and brings up the hologram of
the mind stone you can hear dr. banner
marveling at the fact that he's in front
of such advanced technology as I stated
before while Conda is the most
technologically advanced country in the
MCU and the next part they exchanged
some fancy words which only super
geniuses can understand well II don't
know talking good like me and you
so his vocabulary's limited to I and M
and group exclusively in that ordinate
ok what's basically happening here is
that Bruce Banner is the one who created
Ultron and sure he's the one that's
trying to save him banner explains how
he created vision and then sharee asked
him why he didn't create him in a
different way that's clearly much better
banner briefly thinking about why he
didn't actually do it realizing that it
is much better and also probably
realizing that a teenager is smarter
than him replies because we didn't think
of it and then Sheree proceeds to roast
him you just reprogrammed the synopsis
to work collectively because we didn't
think of it I'm sure you did your best
you have the right to remain
if you also notice you can see in the
background Captain America Black Panther
and the Scarlet Witch right next to
vision this is obviously a very serious
manner considering that Thanos is after
all the Infinity stones and when he goes
to get the mind sound home most likely
kill vision to get it so obviously they
want to do everything they possibly can
to keep the mind stone from getting in
the hands of Thanos and to save visions
life you can also notice the Scarlet
Witch standing right next to him you can
tell from Captain America Civil War and
from the trailers of Infinity Ward that
there is some sort of relationship
between them and I'm excited for this
movie to explore that relationship well
that's it for the clip it's a nice
little sneak peek that we've got from
Good Morning America before we see the
actual movie in just 9 days yeah let me
know what you guys think or if you have
any ideas of your own in the comment
section below be sure to like this video
and subscribe to my channel to stay
up-to-date on Avengers infinity war
Marvel and all things superhero thank
you so much for watching
woof woof we're gonna need some help
how you been [ __ ] not bad for the end of
the world